what's up steve
how are you
i'm good man how are you
uh i've seen all of season two of the
morning show and i'm gonna say great job
thank you
much appreciate it i haven't seen
anything so i'm going in blind
uh well i mean i i think you might have
had access to the scripts so it's
possible you know where it's gonna go
i know some story stuff but i haven't
seen it yet so i'm glad to hear that uh
that you liked it oh yeah fans are gonna
love it there's there's no getting
around that um so before we get into
morning show and i have a lot of
questions um if you could get the
financing for any project what would you
make and why
man what a question you know um the
truth of the matter is lately i've just
been financing my own projects i'm i'm
i'm in the john cassavetes mode act on
the morning show take the money go make
little movies like language lessons that
makes me happy you know um so i don't
really have aspirations for
for big budget things but
i think if if if like the marvel or dc
universe came to me and said we want to
really try something super different we
want to give you a ton of money and we
want to take one of these characters and
yes we want to do five big set pieces
but we want to focus on
crazy interpersonal dynamics and have
you do your exact tone inside of this
universe
that would be interesting to me i don't
know if i could pull it off but it'll be
interesting
i think you'd have more of a chance with
dc than marvel at this point
all right
no i'm just i mean i'm sure you saw
joker and you see what they're
you know and they're they're taking more
they're taking more
one-shot approaches to some of their
characters yeah and marvel is clearly
marvel
yes i get it i get what you're saying
yep
yeah i would like to see it by the way
no [ __ ]
all right well we'll go let's we'll
sidebar we'll go give him a call yeah
we'll call jason keller and just be like
hey
let's take a chance um so jumping into
why i get to talk to you um
when did you find out you never really
know with the show like did you know you
were definitely coming back for season
two um was that like you know because
you never really know if with all the
changes especially it's a good question
yeah i mean look i had a contract for it
they told me they loved me they told me
they wanted me back but you know i'm an
actor and when you
see that your character gets fired from
their job there's the insecurity that
goes off like are they trying to get rid
of me who did i say something bad um but
they quickly kind of let me know that
there was a an agenda for season two
with chip and and so they set me at ease
uh do you think that alex
is a good person a bad person or does it
depend on the day of the week
uh i think alex is a very complicated
person um i think that uh there's a
little bit of uh sociopathy going on
there um there's definitely a massive
ego um and i think that um
years of being in the spotlight and
being
uh told that she is the greatest thing
on earth and then having to put on this
persona you know every morning live um
has really screwed her up but i think at
her core
she's a good person
uh the the one of the reasons why i love
your work on the show and i love the way
you work with jennifer the the dynamic
between you two is just so good uh can
you sort of talk about what it's like
behind the scenes for the two of you
when you're filming some of these
especially emotionally charged scenes
yeah i mean look i i'm in love with jen
i just love her so much and she has been
like one of the best scene partners i
think i've ever had um
and i think that part of why the chip
and alex dynamic is
um what it is and why they leaned into
it so much is because jen and i do love
working together and we and we had that
chemistry the writers decided to lead
into that for season two um
and so i think the reason why there is a
sense of humor a sense of levity a sense
of love between them
um is because jen and i feel that way
about each other if you look at the
dynamic between chip and alex just on
the page it looks horrible it looks like
they hate each other but we bring that
sense of love because i think it is kind
of the way we feel about each other
uh i love learning about the behind the
scenes of the making of of anything what
do you think maybe would surprise fans
of the morning show to learn about the
actual making of the show
well it's a massive show with a massive
budget there's no doubt about that right
you know and whenever i show up i'm so
interested to look at it because i make
movies that are so small and so you know
tiny budget but surprisingly we function
with a lot of the mores of a low budget
show we are moving fast because we're
running out of time we often don't have
enough time to you know get the dolly
shot out and get the get the shot the
way we want it we maybe only have time
for for two takes of something uh god we
can't go to this location so let's
rewrite it and put it on the stage and i
just find that
fascinating that a show at this budget
and scale we're still quote-unquote
cutting corners like i do on my little
hundred thousand dollar movies
yeah that's so it's so interesting but i
think a lot of people don't realize how
how
what it really takes to make something
like this you know it's like an
hour-long movie every seven eight days
so i don't know what your shooting
schedule is
yeah yeah we shoot uh longer than that
um but it it really is and and i i don't
envy the show runners jobs on this
because they have so many talented
actors and so many story lines that
they're juggling and ultimately there's
more that they can fit into that hour
long so you know they're they're
constantly as they as we say in this
industry killing their babies about
which which storylines are they going to
focus on and which ones get shaved back
a little bit you know but what i really
commend them on this season um is
bringing forward you know some story
lines for some actors who
have really shown up on this show have
been incredible on screen have been
incredible behind the scenes people like
karen pittman and dashawn terry they
really get like their due this season
bringing on greta lee for a storyline
this season who's an actor i've just
loved forever giving her a chance to
show her dramatic chops like they
they've they've done a really good job
of giving the platform to the people who
really deserve it
well that's the thing i think that why i
think season two is so good is that and
you've just touched on it is that all
the characters have a good arc you know
they all have something going on which
all melds together if you will um
uh i am curious with um uh
what do you think with kovid i know that
originally sorry this question got
butchered originally you guys started
shooting and then kovitz shut you guys
down and i know they they tweaked the
scripts to incorporate the covet of it
all
did did your storyline change a lot do
you know as a result of the rewriting or
was it pretty much what it was that's a
good question you know we didn't have
all the scripts before we were shut down
so i don't fully know what the storyline
was just to be perfectly honest um
but i know it changed insofar as we
incorporated the covet element and and
they did it in a very fun way where they
introduce it
almost like uh you know you're watching
a horror movie where the audience knows
what the villain is but the characters
don't and you're watching it creep in
from the sides and i really thought that
was a fun way to do it um
and i i know that
they did choose to lean more into
uh the alex and chip storylines uh once
the rewrites happened because there was
some discussion about what do we really
want to be focusing on here um we won't
have as much you know of a of a robust
budget going back in to reshoot
everything because we've already shot
some stuff um
and so
they were being smart and careful about
the kinds of scenes that really were
going to
move the needle and i think that
this is me projecting but if i had to
guess i think they were thinking
mark and jen have really great chemistry
together we can kind of put those two in
a room and it'll work and those are good
cheap scenes to make let's let's use
this as some bread and butter you know
and i think i think that's reflected in
the show yeah i think fans are gonna dig
episodes nine and ten i gotta go i'm
gonna say thank you so much for your
time and congrats on a great season
cheers steve i was good to talk to you